in this video we'll be talking about
thyroid cancer this is a USMLE step one
high yield video stay tuned till the end
thyroid cancer is increasing day by day
and worldwide it's a big concern
so let us look at the cellular
presentation of the thyroid gland tumors
so this is a generic presentation of a
thyroid gland tumor so if we cut a cross
section across the tumor we would see
this is the normal thyroid follicle
here you can see thyroid follicular
cells lining the follicle and inside
that there would be colloid
and the colloid is enriched with
thyroglobulin which is the raw material
for making thyroid hormone and now let's
look at a transformed follicle
which has undergone an oncogenic
transformation
these cells are highly irregular in
shape and size
they have bigger nucleus more mitotic
cells and increased thyroglobulin
content in the follicle
also there are adhesion defects so these
are generic features however there are
many subtypes and the features are not
same for each subtype of cancer so let
us delve into the classification of
thyroid gland cancers
it can be classified as papillary
thyroid carcinoma which is the most
common type accounting for more than 80
percent of all the cancers
and it is typically
present in young women and has a
favorable prognosis
then we'll talk about follicular thyroid
carcinoma which is second most common
accounts for 10 to 15 percent of all
thyroid cancers and it is more common in
areas with iodine deficiency
it has a higher risk of distance
metastasis that is why the situation is
more complicated in follicular thyroid
carcinoma then there is medullary
thyroid carcinoma so unlike the
follicular cell the para follicular C
cells are affected in this case and this
is associated with elevated level of
serum calcitonin and it might be
sporadic or hereditary
then there is anaplastic thyroid
carcinoma which is very aggressive but
also very rare
and it has a poor prognosis
so let's talk about the papillary
carcinoma first papillary carcinoma
appears as an irregular solid cystic
Mast or nodule in the normal thyroid
parenchyma so this is how our cross
section or histology of a normal thyroid
gland look like you can see large
follicles filled with colloids and
lining the follicles there are
follicular cells but this is a papillary
carcinoma cross section here anybody can
appreciate there are empty appearing
nucleus with Central clearing which is a
very common feature in this case
also there is samoma bodies which is
round collection of calcium and can be
seen under microscope this is very
Hallmark of papillary carcinoma
and this this particular carcinoma has
high risk with many mutations like red
mutations PTC mutations BDF mutations or
sometimes it it has a correlation with
childhood irradiation
so the papillary carcinoma
are generally metastatic papillonic
arcinoma has a tendency to metastasize
to early local lymph node with more than
50 percent of patient having nodal
involvement at presentation so lymph
node involvement is there
and basically the ipsilateral jugular
chain of lymph nodes are affected first
in 50 of the children and 20 percent of
the adult the cervical lymph nodes are
palpable and can be detectable okay can
be detected by the time of diagnosis
just by palpating that
now follicular carcinoma is bit
different microscopically these cancer
shows features like microfolecules with
nuclear enlargement
overlapping and crowding
so sometimes there are no too minimal
colloid present in the follicle you can
see the histological section here there
are very less amount of colloid there
and the Nuclear
So The Irregular nuclear size is pretty
much a distinctive feature of this
cancer
so there are moderate to no cytoplasm
so here is the clinical Focus
generally there might be invasiveness of
this cancer so obviously it has the
capability of metastasis and that's what
basically differentiate it from the
follicular adenoma
now medullary carcinoma
is the carcinoma for C cells C cells are
the cells in the thyroid gland that
secretes calcitonin
so there are sheets of polygonal cells
in an amyloid stroma so one can clearly
understand there is a hyperplasia of the
C cells
this particular cancer is associated
with Min to A Min to B mutations and red
mutations
so let us look at some clinical
presentation
so generally this kind of cancer
presents with painless thyroid Mass
which is called on scanning up to 70
percent of the patients have nodal
metastasis mostly involving Central
compartments ipsilateral and
contralateral jubular carotid chains are
also involved
so there are diagnostic biomarkers which
is elevated serum calcitonin serum
calcitonin high level of serum
calcitonin basically correlates with
tumor burden
and there are few important things to
remember that patients with this kind of
cancer would have diarrhea and flushing
most tumors may also produce
dysregulation in ACTH and crh might lead
to Cushing syndrome as well
then there is anaplastic thyroid
carcinoma which is the rarest form and
this is kind of like undifferentiated
tumors of the thyroid follicular
epithelium
so this arise from pre-existing tumor as
well mostly associated with papillary
carcinoma rarest of all the cancer
thyroid cancers and is extremely
aggressive in 80 percent of the cases
the mortality rate is very high
so the anaplastic carcinoma has no
distinct distinctive histological
features it's highly variable sometimes
there are squamous presentation there
are giant cells or sometimes there could
be spindle like cells as well so there
are no unified feature that distinguish
anaplastic thyroid carcinoma it's poorly
characterized that's why it has a very
poor prognosis
anyway extra thyroidal extension is
Major in the majority of the cases have
been seen
so the clinical presentation in includes
20 to 50 percent of have prior
multinodule or goiter 20 percent have
concurrent differentiated carcinoma 20
percent have prior differentiated
carcinoma so a prior involvement of any
kind of cancer is associated with
anaplastic thyroid carcinoma
anyway so the metastasis can happen for
anaplastic thyroid carcinoma so there
could be primary and secondary
metastasis as well so there are Regional
metastases which are pretty common
feature of any thyroid cancer but apart
from that distant metastasis also happen
basically metastasis can happen in
muscle trachea esophagus larynge larynx
Etc
also very distant metastasis like bone
or brain can also be involved in rare
situations
so let's quickly review the mutations
which are associated with thyroid cancer
so there are different type of thyroid
cancer and with of so three of them are
actually associated with the follicular
cells and medullary carcinoma is
associated with the parafollicular cells
so papillary carcinoma is associated
with braf v600e mutation
PTC mutations
follicular carcinoma is associated with
brass and pax8 ppir Gamma translocations
anaplastic carcinoma is associated with
rasmutations and medullary carcinoma is
generally associated with red mutations
so basically these are the important
mutations which are associated with the
thyroid cancer
so there are a lot of signaling Pathways
which are associated with thyroid cancer
and goes wrong in these cancer
understanding that is a royal pain in
this video we can't understand all of
the pathways but we can focus on one
so one of the key pathway that gets
abrogated is a receptor tyrosine kinase
and growth factor signaling pathway
so upon growth factor binding there are
grb2 SOS and shc binding to that these
are General adapters then there are
Keras in Ras or HRS activation which
further activates B ref then make then
Arc and Arc eventually gets
phosphorylated and translocates into the
nucleus eventually it leads to uh
production or it leads to transcription
of the gene which lead to growth
survival or even proliferation
it also lead to the gene activation
which lead to tumor promoting kind of
function or anti-apoptotic function
so overall there are B ref mutations
which are found in case of thyroid
cancers
so basically B ref v600e is pretty
common
and also it's a druggable Target and
that is how it can be treated also
phosphoric can be treated with specific
small molecule Inhibitors as well
later on we'll talk about it so these
kind of drugs would prevent the growth
survival or proliferation
so when it comes to diagnosis fine
needle aspiration biopsy is the common
mode of diagnosis
apart from a biopsy sometimes serum
biomarkers could be distinct for example
in in case of medullary carcinoma
elevated level of calcitonin could be a
diagnostic biomarker imaging studies
could be useful especially the Pet Scan
and Pet City scans so in in the Pet Scan
one can clearly see what the cancer is
located where it is metastasized all
these can kind of information can be
found from pet scans
then High throughput sequencing these
days can shed more light on the subtype
or the subclassification of the cancer
it would be easy for the treat treatment
purposes
now here comes the staging of thyroid
cancer
so American Joint Committee of cancer or
ajcc has defined a staging system where
they classify stage one tumors to be
less than two centimeter in size and
generally
they do not spread to the lymph node or
any distance sites stage 2 is some kind
of tumor which is more than two
centimeter in size but still they do not
metastasize stage 3 is that particular
tumor which is big and also they have
started metastasizing into the lymph
nodes in the neck region
and stage 4 is the tumor which is very
aggressive and might have spread to the
other part of the body so distance
metastasis is basically stage four all
these classification are generally valid
for papillary and follicular
carcinoma but the classification system
for medullary and anaplastic is not so
linear they have different criterias so
let's just not get into too much
complexity right now
so let's talk about the treatment
options for thyroid cancer so obviously
there could be surgical removal of the
region there could be chemotherapy and
radiation therapy and there are specific
small molecular Inhibitors which we
previously talked about which can Target
specific molecule can be
serving as a targeted medication for
thyroid cancer so for these kind of
medication the deeper understanding of
cellular signaling and molecular
pathways are really crucial
so I hope this video was informative get
such videos and flashcards in our
Facebook and Instagram page links are
provided in the description you can
support our Channel using super tanks
see you in next video
good